we've been counting down the days to
next 2023 with some sneak peeks of duet
AI in Google cloud and I'm sharing some
first looks at how Google has been
working hard on a new product to make
your Cloud development experience better
so let's take a look at our final sneak
peek of the week soon you'll be able to
use duet AI in Google Cloud to get unit
tests for your code and if you have
conditional statements in your function
it'll generate tests for each case but
beyond IDE power chat and developer
tools AI powered chat will be infused
into the entire Google Cloud console for
all users on every page so you'll be
able to ask for Ops guidance tips on the
products that you want to use best
practices and even CLI commands but
you'll need to tune into next to learn
more make sure you claim your
complementary access digital pass online
and we'll see you at next